one year ago researchers at the visa
Institute announced that they had
developed a method for fabricating a
fully biodegradable bioplastic by
extracting a form of chitin from shrimp
shells this new material can be molded
into everyday objects in a manner
similar to synthetic plastics but
without an environmental threat chitin
which was first discovered in the 1800's
has been long believed by scientists to
be a molecule that exists solely in
invertebrates animals without backbones
such as insects and shrimp and serves as
a crucial component of their
exoskeletons as the work at the VESA
Institute unfolded Javier Fernandez a
key researcher on the project also
started exploring other potential
sources of chitin in nature with
collaborators from Harvard University
and Arroyo Research Institute and the
University of Washington the team
recently discovered small amounts of
chitin in fish and amphibians such as
salamanders the implications of these
findings could be significant crop
industries have used pesticides for the
last half century and Libet paetynn
growth
intended to control insect populations
by stunting the formation of their
exoskeletons without having an impact on
the surrounding ecology and environment
the red-colored area on this photo
indicates the presence of chitin
zebrafish and here the red colored area
reveals titan the salamanders limb
following Fernandez's new findings the
definition of chitin has to change how
has decades of chitin limiting
pesticides affected these animals we
just don't know what we do know though
is that we once work to better
understand Titans purpose and
developmental biology we must never stop
questioning or investigating the world
around us
you